miles ago red but it's fair to mat and
welcome to troubling Tyra's town it's a
really funny game one guy is a trainer
and the rest are the innocent and they
have to figure out who it is
so let's go the [ __ ] is going on okay
I'm gonna be honest this time I'm
actually a traitor
I don't trust do we see am i doesn't
Matt oh [ __ ]
I just don't just shoot I think it's
minx wait well I don't know so dudes a
solution shot me who shot him
I'm gonna shot me over there you see
somebody just shot someone there over
here wait no who shot him
I don't know he wasn't what did it makes
is quiet what happened I shall spoon die
this is a tower whose shadow in the
tower
sure come on again is it mixed Oh what
it's not me what are you talking about
boo did she blow you up so she could I
ignored that day LMG I'm a promise I'll
do it
did someone say Ellen DeGeneres no a LMG
okay look I threw grenades hey I got my
gun it's Ellen DeGeneres she's she's the
bomb [ __ ] out laughter f Ellen kills
people
she is repairing [ __ ] with Ellen I can
see her eyes
oh you're on my suspicious list you're
my sister's [ __ ] me he's a traitor
yeah over the way Oh guys you're doing
good
oh hey you're the traitor traitor
you're the traitor go out here right now
okay I'm coming around hey this is so
funny oh this is so tense
oh so I got a crowbar oh yes yeah you
had me so tight dude good I didn't mean
to shoot you but yeah hey taking shots
at me look at all the blood on the wall
go what you shot me I came out as a
realization you get what's up and you
like don't feel like snow please leave
me alone
what I it's max it's definitely max can
tell the time
oh no oh oh stop
that even left a big like [ __ ] shoot
first I know students bottom is a boy
everything to taste the fine Mallory's
you spit all the food that's amazing
okay I'm innocent this it's not the
wrong way we can decide him traitor I
want you all to come to the farmers
market I have you some bananas I'm Rose
market but now they'll take some bananas
and the banana French rusty dude I'm not
going there
wait you just walk around the corner I
think she's proven a spoon I can't even
sing e Oh disk involve you later she ran
in a through the later of us are you
years
oh come out with your hands up no no no
playing I'm out with your hands up okay
ha ha ha boots no I miss and you should
have shoot me I don't believe you see
spins
no it's Ming's I'm sweating on it's
Minsk oh wait I don't know if I trust
you though oh yeah told you I'm fine
jerk
sorry look at their names look at their
names
hey I'm fine I'm fine probably now this
is true yeah that's tanzamarie this yeah
everyone is this in a small room now and
touch each other
all right everyone get in their waists
the boots where is it yeah I'm not going
in there yet step up everyone go in
there we have to touch each other hi
okay okay look at this list it's right
here let's go say foodies crude as well
yeah why are you crude some people
that's because you kill a lot anything
yet
much is david mackay hey hey hey it
wasn't me herds are solid I'm innocent
come on since this week speak you [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] mess
Tom you to frenzy I'm almost leavin
guesses okay [ __ ] you covered anus is
right in my face
oh yeah judge it may be a lie max wait
be that you're taking shots at me
Fuji right okay I might tell me to put a
new face on this it's all of a cute
Emily I I don't know the runner garnet I
didn't know the Robin started what you
thought it was me you dick come back
here you [ __ ] oh I'm sorry yes it
matters
sorry's not gonna say okay better I
promise
I hope you enjoyed watching maybe like
if you did a house matter a lot it's a
really funny game and I'm super happy to
share it with you breath anyway stay
awesome bros love you oh no I'm not a
bottle I had never wore a bottle and I
never
okay I got away I got away - morning
Oh
[Music]